the Army has changed its pitches here is
the new US Army
AD stand
up there's okay I've seen a lot of
straight looking white guys seen more
straight looking white guys than I've
seen in any army ad in recent memory and
then they wow and there's it's not
social activism they're just jumping out
of helicopters with
parachutes the greatest victories are
never achieved alone be all you can be
even a return to the old US Army motto
when I was a kid be all that you can
be be all you can be oh man we're going
to war we're going to war I felt better
about our prospects for peace back when
the US Army ads did not focus on men
fighting and preparing to kill our
enemies back when the US Army ads
focused on
women bragging about their lesbian
mothers I suppose one of them is
probably the mother and going to Pride
parades and festivals and rallies
growing up begins in
California with a little girl raised by
two
moms I also marched for
equality I like to think I've been
defending freedom from an early
age when I was 6 years old one of my
moms had an accident that left her
paralyzed but she tapped into my
family's Pride to get back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other
mom and after meeting with an army
recruiter I found it a way to prove my
inner
strength I'm US Army Corporal Emma
Malone Lord and I answered my
calling let me translate that ad for you
that was not that long ago that that ad
came out the translation of that ad is
hey normal
patriotic conservative dude D who have
made up the bulk of the US military for
all of our nation's history yeah go away
we don't want you we don't want you guys
and why why would the libs who control
the military at the top level the vast
majority of people in the US military
remain normal and Furious at their
leadership but I'm talking about the the
mark Millies of the world I'm talking
about the chairman and the joint Chief
screaming about white rage and now we
need to teach our recruits
critical race Theory and why why is the
Army leadership doing that why were they
doing that right now I go to
helixsleep.com with everything going on
in the world right now you could really
use a good night's sleep that is why you
need to check out Helix mattress the
Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses
including the award-winning Lux
collection the newly released Helix
Elite collection a mattress designed for
Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids I've had my
Helix for years now and I absolutely
love it Helix has has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
references to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else go to
helixsleep.com
canw take their two-minute sleep quiz to
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type their flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
KW use Helix partner2 that's my nickname
that's what they used to call me in high
school this is their best offer yet it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts right about now
because at the level of leadership those
jobs become very very
political at the level of enlisted guys
and most officers even still most
officers they're serving their country
with plain not not exactly partisan
motives but when you get to those top
top levels those politically appointed
levels with a lot of influence from
Washington obviously those become very
very party political and I I think the
left saw that they had a problem which
is the left saw that they had conquered
Academia the news media Hollywood
Corporate America that took them a
little longer but they managed to
conquer Corporate America they obviously
had the bureaucracy they had a lot of
the elected government basically
everything except for the military the
military remained pretty much the one
Institution the conservatives still had
and so they set out very intentionally
to conquer the military and one way to
do that is to use the military to push a
lot of woke propaganda another way to do
that is to brainwash the new recruits
and teach them critical race Theory and
have them understand white rage and
another way to do that is to convince
the conservatives not to join up anyway
so they put out this advertisement this
advertisement I think was less about
recruiting new people to the Army as it
was about
discouraging the normal kind of the
older kind of people from joining the
Army saying hey you straight white guys
hey you conservatives hey you get out of
here we don't want your kind anymore now
the issue
is
no Army has ever won a war when it was
made up primarily of leftist woke
lesbians that I can't I was a history
major in school history buff as an adult
I've never read about that Army victory
for Any Nation ever in the history of
the world when you when you want to win
Wars you need extremely tough masculine
brutes who want to go in and kill the
enemy you know George Patton speech to
the third army war is a bloody killing
business when your best friend beside
you is blown up and you got his guts all
over your face you'll know what to do
kill the enemy go through that enemy
like a hot knife through butter like s
hit
through a tin can or whatever they said
uh that's what you want
and so now that we're on the brink of
World War III again you'll notice the
ads
shifting I I guess in a way it's good
that the the Army is is recognizing that
you know Pride parades are not going to
win a a war but bad news in that they
fear that they will have to win a war
that we will all have to win a war soon
boy what a great clip that was now hey
hey hey hey hey man ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael's YouTube
channel we'll see you next time